in this video I'm going to take some
time to talk about the culture of the
young United States that developed in
the early 19th century at the beginning
of this period most of the dominant
artistic and cultural productions in the
United States the paintings architecture
literature and even philosophy or either
borrowed from or imitations of what was
being produced in Europe the United
States itself was born in the midst of
an intellectual movement that crossed
the Atlantic from Europe the
Enlightenment and if you read the
Declaration of Independence you can hear
the echoes of the Enlightenment we hold
these truths to be self-evident that all
men are created equal that they are
endowed by their creator with certain
unalienable rights that among these are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness that to secure these rights
governments are instituted among men
deriving their just powers from the
consent of the governed
Jefferson looks at the evidence the
rational reasons for self-government now
contrast that with a piece of writing
from an American at the end of this
period here's the last stanza from Edgar
Allen Poe's poem The Raven first
published in 1845 and the Raven never
flitting still is sitting still is
sitting on the pallid bust of Pallas
just above my chamber door and his eyes
have all the seeming of a demons that is
dreaming and the lamplight o'er him
streaming throws his shadow on the floor
and my soul from out that shadow that
lies floating on the floor shall be
lifted Nevermore what is going on here
Poe's talking about demons and souls and
shadows is clearly not interested in
reason or logic where Jefferson is cold
Poe is hot emotional imaginative
concentrating on the unseen world
instead of the observable world that
Jefferson Prizes this is because Poe
writing nearly seventy years later was a
product of the Romantic era the
romantics rebelled against the
Enlightenment ideas of Pure Reason
the scientific method arguing instead
that individual experience and emotion
mattered more so why do we care about
this transition from the Enlightenment
to the Romantic era in the history of
the United States well for one thing
because it helps us explain the Second
Great Awakening that period of intense
religious devotion that emerged in the
first half of the 19th century and drove
not only a creation of new religious
movements in the United States but also
major reform movements but we also care
because it was during this time of
transition that the first truly American
art and literary movements emerged
artists and writers stopped merely
imitating European styles although they
were certainly still influenced by them
and began trying to capture a unique and
different American culture what they
produce not only tells us a lot about
their time period but also created the
foundation of what's considered American
art or American literature today one of
the ways that Americans began to
distinguish their culture was through
architecture in the late 1700s American
architecture started to move away from
the Georgian style it had borrowed from
Britain the various symmetrical brick
homes that were built during the era
when kings named George were in power
and they started to draw more from the
models of Roman and Greek architecture
Americans saw themselves as carrying on
the traditions of the Roman Republic and
Greek democracy
so they started employing some of the
same architectural language the federal
style started incorporating Roman
elements into Georgian buildings like
Roman arches here you can see a bit of
the transition from this Georgian
building on Harvard's campus to this
Federal Building in Salem Massachusetts
you go from square windows and doors to
Roman arches and this transition
continued as the US Capitol was built in
Washington DC starting in the 1820s the
Greek Revival style became prominent for
monumental buildings incorporating
triangular pediments and Greek columns
here you can see the original design of
the US Capitol building which houses
Congress it has a central dome like the
Pantheon in Rome and then a full-on
Greek temple pasted to its face by
adopting these elements American
architects sent the message that the
United States wasn't just imitating
British styles instead they were
crafting an architectural form that was
suitable for a republic American art
also began to diverge from its European
forebears during the early 19th century
american-born painters in the
Revolutionary era like Gilbert Stuart
went to Europe to study and start their
careers before heading back to the
United States
Stuart's portraits of important American
figures like George Washington followed
the conventions of classical portraiture
it wasn't until the 1820 is that
American art began to come into its own
with the Hudson River school this was
started by a group of painters working
in upstate New York who captured the
majestic nature of the American
landscape they were influenced by the
Romantic movements emphasis on emotion
and the sublime which is the inspiring
untamed aspect of nature that you find
in mountains and storms and wilderness
the painters of the Hudson River School
explored the relationship between the
American environment and the march of
settlement let's take a look at one
Hudson River School painting the Oxbow
which was painted in 1836 by Thomas Cole
the painting depicts a bends in the
Connecticut River in western
Massachusetts you can see that a
thunderstorm is passing with dark clouds
here on the left and there's this
twisted tree and downed limbs which show
how violent the storm was up on the
mountain
it feels dangerous and unpredictable
that's the sublime right there then on
the right side you have this River
Valley with farms and little plumes of
smoke from houses there's a boat on the
river and some sheep grazing down here
and just barely visible on the
foreground is a little self portrait of
Thomas Cole out with his
Diezel he's kind of saying yeah that's
right I'm out here dodging lightning to
show you how the real deal looks so you
can see in this painting that there's
kind of a tension between the settled
society on the right side and the
wilderness on the left side the vastness
of the American West and the march of
the first wave of industrialization gave
painters a unique American subject for
their art lastly the first American
writers and thinkers came on the scene
during this era remember the romantics
glorified the experience of the
individual and their emotions the first
American fiction writers to gain
traction for an international audience
described unique aspects of American
society Washington Irving who we
remember today for the Headless Horseman
in the Legend of Sleepy Hollow
another romantic ghost story like Poe's
the Raven achieved renowned by telling
folk tales about the lingering Dutch
culture in upstate New York james
fenimore cooper's protagonist in his
leather stocking tales natty bumpo was a
white frontiersman who grew up among the
indigenous delaware people his nickname
was Hawkeye and yes the Marvel character
is named after him which gives you a
sense of how these first American
characters have continued to live on in
our contemporary culture in New England
particularly Boston and the surrounding
areas American intellectuals embraced
Romanticism in the philosophy of
transcendentalism the transit analysts
were a group of writers poets and
philosophers who believed that truth
transcended the observable world of the
Enlightenment and that spiritual meaning
could be found in nature Henry David
Thoreau is probably the most famous
transcendentalist he wrote a book about
his two years living simply in a cabin
he built on the edge of Walden Pond on
fellow transcendentalist Ralph Waldo
Emerson's property the
transcendentalists also emphasized the
individual and freedom of thought an
arson who's generally considered the
founder of the transcendentalist
movement wrote essays encouraging
Americans to think for themselves not
just go along with a crowd some of the
most influential transcendentalists were
women like Margaret Fuller who wrote
about the state of women in the 19th
century and edited the transcendentalist
magazine the diol poet Emily Dickinson
has sometimes been classed among the
transcendentalists as has Louisa May
Alcott the author of Little Women the
freedom of thought that the
transcendentalists espoused also led
them to become some of the strongest
opponents of the institution of slavery
the ROE refused to pay his taxes in
protest of the mexican-american war
which he and many Northerners saw as an
unjust land-grab to extend southern
territory and spread slavery West he
wrote an essay about his experience
called
resistance to civil government sometimes
shortened to civil disobedience which
encouraged individuals not to obey
unjust laws his ideas would go on to
influence Mahatma Gandhi and later
Martin Luther King jr.